Transcription: Dominique Partridge
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Il se dit de belles histoires
qu’elles commencent par :
« Il était une fois ... »
Il est aussi de belles histoires
qui peuvent commencer par un nombre
pour désigner une année : 1969.
Quelle belle histoire que celle
de la conquête de la Lune.
« Un petit pas pour l’homme,
un grand pas pour l’humanité. »
Il est aussi de belles histoires
qui se poursuivent par une période
de l’année, décembre,
un cycle qui s’achève.
Et enfin, il est aussi de belles histoires
qui sont marquées par un autre nombre, 24,
la veille du jour de l’amour, de l’unité,
de la paix, de la famille, qu’est Noël.
Il y a de la joie, de la légèreté,
de l’insouciance, de l’impatience même,
à prendre la route ce soir là pour
retrouver les cousins, les cousines,
les oncles, les tantes,
les grands-parents.
Le père conduit sa voiture.
Les enfants sont avec lui.
La mère, seule, suit derrière
dans un autre véhicule.
La fillette, agenouillée
sur la banquette arrière,
les coudes plantés dans le siège,
envoie des baisers à sa mère
à travers la vitre.
Un baiser envolé.
L'impact.
Arrêt sur image.
La route est grise.
Dure.
Vide.
Le véhicule, désarticulé,
est encastré dans le talus gauche.
Et la fillette le fixe avec
une lucidité déconcertante.
Du haut de ses quatre ans,
elle le défie du regard.
Passer en mode survie.
Se rappeler l'histoire racontée
hier à l'heure du coucher.
Et puis non, surtout pas, parce que
ça va lui faire penser à maman
dont elle sait qu’elle ne reviendra pas.
Alors vite, raconter n’importe quoi et
inventer une autre histoire
pour ne pas pleurer, pour ne pas bouger,
pour ne pas crier.
Se concentrer sur autre chose.
Ne pas vouloir déranger.
Vouloir être invisible.
Se débrouiller seule avec ce qu'elle voit,
ce qu'elle entend.
Et puis ce n’est pas grave si on la laisse
seule sur le bord de la route.
L'important, ce n'est pas elle.
C'est maman, c'est l'amour
qu'il faut sauver.
C'est impossible.
Mais elle n’a pas d’autre choix
que d’espérer.
La fillette a maintenant huit ans.
Elle est un peu moins rachitique.
Ses cheveux, que maman coiffait
en un épais chignon,
ont été coupés à la garçonne.
Son attitude est inchangée.
Elle demeure à la lisière du monde,
au bord des choses.
Mais attention de ne pas se méprendre.
Bien plus que rester à l’écart,
elle écoute,
elle sent,
elle observe, elle remarque...
...cette autre fillette qui,
depuis la rentrée des classes,
reste seule sous le préau
au moment des récréations.
Ses chaussures sont fatiguées.
Ses vêtements sont défraîchis.
Elle n’a pas de sacoche pour mettre
un goûter, un paquet de bonbons,
parce que pour elle, tout cela,
c’est bien plus qu’un luxe.
Alerter les copines, organiser une quête
avec un franc par-ci, un franc par-là,
on peut en offrir des douceurs.
Et puis, on peut partager un goûter,
jouer ensemble.
Donner un peu de chaleur.
Quand je serai grande, se dit la fillette,
je veux aider les autres.
Pas question de laisser quelqu'un
seul sur le bord de la route.
L’adolescence se passe dans
une atmosphère austère, monacale.
Belle-maman a réparti les rôles
de façon arbitraire.
Le père s’occupe de son fils, l’aîné.
Elle, elle prend l'adolescente
sous sa coupe.
En d’autres termes,
les temps de partage, de convivialité,
de complicité et d’amour,
sont quasi inexistants.
C'est une des conditions de leur remariage
de raison pour le père.
Une situation que l'adolescente
vit comme un abandon.
Et puis, le frère quitte la maison
pour poursuivre ses études.
Il s'échappe.
Elle reste.
Plus tard, se dit l’adolescente,
je veux penser à ceux
qui se sentent seuls,
qui se sentent isolés.
Attention, il y a de l’amour malgré tout,
mais un amour conditionné,
qui se mérite,
en étant toujours
et en tout, la meilleure.
Mais quel sens y a-t-il à être
la meilleure par rapport aux autres?
Ce qu’elle, elle veut, c’est être
la meilleure pour les autres,
apporter le meilleur
de ce qu’elle est à chacun
parce que toute personne, quelle que soit
son histoire, a son importance.
L’humanitaire, ça n’est pas un métier,
tranche belle-maman,
le baccalauréat obtenu.
Passé un immense sentiment
d’incompréhension, d’injustice,
Aline se pose la question
de la désobéissance.
La réflexion sera rondement menée.
Pour aider les autres, il faut comprendre
comment fonctionne le monde.
Il faut des compétences, alors soit, pour
des études supérieures qui faciliteront
l'action le moment venu.
Une rencontre avec
le professeur Montagnier ;
un préambule à des levées de fonds
pour financer la recherche
sur la transmission du VIH
de la mère à l’enfant ;
des reportages pour témoigner
du mode de vie
des derniers aborigènes de Thaïlande ;
un partenariat avec une ONG
internationale pour dénoncer
l’utilisation des mines antipersonnel dans
les conflits armés d’Asie du Sud-Est ;
des actions de soutien
au centre nutritionnel de Phnom Penh
et auprès d’orphelinats au Cambodge.
Malgré toutes les années,
j’espère que Sarak a gardé
sa joie de vivre.
Quand nous nous sommes rencontrés en 2003,
à l’orphelinat de Battambang,
au centre du Cambodge,
il apprenait à marcher avec une prothèse
en guise de jambe droite.
Debout,
devant un miroir,
il tentait de se réapproprier
son image, son identité.
Sarak avait douze ans.
Il avait marché
sur une mine antipersonnel.
Ces choix, auquel j’ai consacré
la moitié de mon temps,
sont à la mesure de mon existence.
Ils sont modestes, minuscules,
mais ils sont ma raison d’être.
Et puis, il y a eu ce voyage à Bornéo ;
je voulais voir des orangs-outans.
Une demi-journée à rouler sur une piste
de latérite obstinément droite.
De part et d’autre,
des allées de palmiers à huile tirées
au cordeau à boucher l’horizon.
Une géométrie de la démesure,
de la désolation.
Ma pensée, alors, elle a été claire.
Nous sommes allés trop loin.
Mais je peux, à mon niveau,
contribuer à influencer
le cours des choses.
Et c’est ainsi que je suis tombée
dans le développement durable
et la responsabilité sociétale
de l’entreprise
pour en faire mon métier,
depuis bientôt 20 ans.
De tous les pays que j’ai connus,
c’est la Polynésie que mon cœur a choisi.
Pour son authenticité, sa chaleur humaine,
son humilité ;
au sens où l’humilité
est cette posture par laquelle l’homme
s’incline devant la nature,
devant sa terre natale,
devant la terre de ses ancêtres.
Les femmes de Polynésie sont des passeurs.
Elles transmettent la culture, l’histoire,
les valeurs, la langue.
Par leurs engagements,
par leur capacité à entreprendre,
à innover, à conduire le changement,
elles sont à la fois des vahinés « aito »,
des femmes guerrières,
et des vahinés « arata’i »,
des femmes guides,
dont les actions doivent être
encouragées et promues.
C’est la mission de l’association
que j’ai créée en 2017
et qui, depuis deux ans, a une consœur
en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Si j’avais pu choisir la route empruntée
par mes parents,
le 24 décembre 1969,
de toute évidence, je n’aurais pas
pris le même chemin.
J'aurais nourri des ambitions différentes.
J’ai gagné, là où j’aurais pu perdre.
Je me suis égarée,
là où j’aurais pu l’emporter.
J’aurais ri, j’aurais pleuré,
j’aurais aimé.
Je me serais indignée
pour des causes différentes.
Je n'aurais pas eu la chance
de vous rencontrer.
Je ne serais tout simplement pas Aline.
Sans histoire,
nous ne sommes rien.
Sans connaître notre propre histoire,
nous sommes peu.
Elle fait de nous des êtres uniques,
exceptionnels.
Elle est notre identité.
Notre histoire, il faut la feuilleter
comme un livre de chevet,
avec bienveillance, avec gratitude.
Elle nous guide dans nos pensées,
dans nos choix, dans nos actions.
Pour continuer à grandir chaque jour
davantage, dans la confiance,
dans l’harmonie, dans l’amour,
il nous faut admettre que c’est
ce que nous n’avons pas choisi
qui fait ce que nous sommes.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)